Dwayne Johnson story you said Hollywood
star Dwayne Johnson confirms that
running for president is off the table
the most important thing to me is being
a daddy I love our country and everyone
in it I also love being a daddy and
that's the most important thing to me is
being a daddy especially during this
time this critical time in my daughter's
lives I know that I know what it's like
to be on the road and to be busy that I
was absent for a lot of years the actor
continued the Hollywood star has three
children four-year-old Tiana Johnson
six-year-old Jasmine Johnson and his 21
year old Simone Johnson so uh him saying
he's not running what are your thoughts
on this story I just think
good come I'm glad you came out and said
it I think there's just been this
propensity for like any Hollywood
celebrity can just be the president now
right whether it's Oprah or Tom Hanks or
the rock Michelle or anything Matthew
McConaughey or just go be president
because you're popular I think it it
takes a little bit more nuance and
education uh Trump different type of
person because he's been a businessman
for all those years and he's been
donating to politics for all this long
and I know that Pat you said to make it
in Hollywood you kind of have to have
some politics and be able to kind of
maneuver through the idiosyncrasies and
of how Hollywood works but I do think
you know people people say they don't
want a career politician which I agree
with to a certain extent but I also
don't want someone who's green behind
the ears that has never been a
politician in their life just because
they've been an actor or a wrestler for
20 30 years doesn't qualify them to be
freaking president of the United States
do you think it's that hard to be like a
president of a country that yeah has a
system put in place well I mean Trump
kicked ass policy wise because he's been
pro-american for his whole life but I
mean the powers that be don't let you go
off the rails you know I mean so doing
the rock could easily a get the vote and
win and just if he has ideas or whatever
but he's not really steering the ship
you know what I mean I just wonder how
long it genuinely truly takes for you to
understand how government works yeah
okay like if you're the Rock and you've
been just smelling what The Rock has
been cooking for the last 20 years all
of a sudden you know how filibusters
work and how you know bill becomes a law
and and what it takes to negotiate with
the other side of the aisle I think we
need to give certain politicians a
little more credit for understanding the
balance of all that works I'm not saying
I'm giving all politicians credit
because I think the majority of them are
[ __ ] idiots however uh certain good
politicians do kind of know what they're
doing out there I would hope what if we
did a test we just take like like
somebody who's like completely clueless
doesn't know what day it is a lot of
committee behind them make decisions
mispronounce things every day and be
basically senile put them in as
president let the committee run it and
just see what happens wait a minute that
sounds really familiar that guy's making
some [ __ ] happen though he's passing
laws buddy who's he doesn't know just
ignore the nukes that are flying over
the top of Japan and Tokyo the fact that
we're down deep in Ukraine keep doubting
out and just keeps oh we will nobody
nobody someone said this the other day
that's her hat so but so Adam going back
to your point so uh Trump donated and
you know was always giving money to
politicians he didn't know nothing about
the laws and filibusters and all that
[ __ ] how was he so successful in that
Arena I don't care about the personality
and you know him you know talking all
the [ __ ] how did he figure it out so
fast he changed policies he stopped you
know trade with uh China he did this he
did the country was kicking ass until
Kobe how did he figure it out so much if
he's such a he was just he's just a
business-minded big mouth you know troll
how did he figure it out I would hope
did he find your lunch Mark yeah thank
you buddy I would hope that he had just
had smart well-informed people around
him so I mean kudos to having smart
people around you so the problem with
Trump is all those people he surrounded
himself do not want to affiliate with
Trump anymore like every General every
person around him
like lit everyone Bill Barr Mike Pence
he did have people in place that were
around him but he's the problem with
Trump is you know you can give him
credit for hiring the right people but I
don't know why he can't maintain these
relationships every single one of them
want nothing to do with Trump anymore
that's his biggest flaw the biggest
asset you could have as a president is
common sense you can read uh how a bill
becomes a law you can read what a
filibuster is we have a whole bunch of
people in Congress and the Senate that
know all that stuff they're completely
useless so what I want is I want
somebody who has Common Sense preferably
somebody who's run a business people who
understand what it means when you raise
taxes on somebody what that does people
who understand basic concepts like the
minimum wage and don't rely on talking
points but have seen those policies
actually affect their business that's
what matters to me I appreciate
Governors because they've actually run a
city or a state but I don't think you
have to know the logistics of government
government is mostly broken institutions
and and overstuff bureaucracy what you
really need is someone in there who's
able to think for themselves who can
hire the right people who doesn't just
surround themselves with Yes Men by
people who will challenge them as well
who isn't afraid to backtrack on
something when they say this is a
mistake let's do it redirect course and
who actually views themselves as a
representative of all people in a
country and isn't a a person who claims
to not be divisive but behind the scenes
is actually incredibly divisive in
policy and whatnot so I actually think
that common sense is the biggest asset
you can have so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you
[Music]